see the everything in the universe is
Contracting and expending right
um you know when you go to sleep
and you wake up in the morning
um day and night uh the seasons or even
when you do weightlifting you're walking
cutting and you know breathing your
inhale and exhales
um
life and death you know
getting on with a girl breaking up with
her
uh your cells like you know Contracting
expending so everything is Contracting
expense so if you since your channel is
called Theory of Everything I'll say The
Theory of Everything if I can describe
it in one sentence is this process of
contraction and expansion so when you go
through a spiritual path when you start
to meditate and when you start to pierce
through the veil of Illusion and getting
to the emptiness of things
each time you have an opening each time
you pierce through the veil of an
illusion and get an opening into the
true nature the balance space of true
nature
some of your subconscious and your
traumas and conditions whatever is
separating you from this bad space
um just this more solidified version of
this space surfaces so you're making the
unconscious conscious or you bring the
shadow to the light so when the shadow
is brought into the light
um you are forced to look at your stuff
right so you can be very uncomfortable
another way to look at Dark Knight of
the soul is the process of the
dissolution of the ego
so if you look at ego as sort of like a
program or a matrix when it gets
attacked we start doing some meditation
practice and you start the scene through
it out the ego is not what you really
are when that program is undergoing
attack it's going to cling on to itself
harder because you know like any other
program if he gets attacked by a virus
it's going to do everything it's powered
to survive so that process can be
extremely uncomfortable so a lot of
people they meditate and meditate oh
everything's great but then suddenly
they go into this state of
depersonalization where they have a
glimpse of their true nature their
emptiness of things but then the other
half of them like they have one that's
put in the empty there's another first
star in the world they have one foot in
you know the vast spaciousness on the
groundless ground and then they still
have another foot in the ground so
they're still trying to hold on to the
ground they're still trying to hold on
to their equal identity while at the
same time having some kind of glimpses
into the infinite nature of reality
so that's where the Dark Knight of the
Soul comes from it's when you expand and
then you contract back again you feel
very uncomfortable
it's kind of like a a withdrawal from
like a really good psychedelic trip or
like you know a bad trip or something
like that
yeah it's like once you once you
experience God in Divinity now you get
to experience hell until you transcend
them both
because they cannot exist without the
other you know people talk about like
you know experiences of Love experience
of God all those great mystical
explosions oh my Consciousness they
exploded to universe that's [__]
great now I feel like a god but then the
other side of that coin is the
contraction you can have expansion with
that contraction that's the loss of
nature do you also have to embrace and
stay Economist to the experiences of
Darkness of the soul and see how this
process of expansion and contraction are
two sides of the same coin and that can
be transcended